[Music]
what did I miss I mean every week I'm
hoping it's the previously on segments
but they just keeping running them come
in home one this is f rep Pete do you
read us over allow me to reiterate how
nonsensical it is or at least the
internet tells me for subbe to be using
a Rebel's erera code name the Empire is
already more than aware of thanks to
thraw and agent callus and if you won't
allow me to reiterate then Cy can just
do it if we can't make the journey to
find Ezra then no one should that is Far
and Away the creepiest if I can't have
him you can't either I've ever heard
he'd be stranded out there maybe this
time for good better that than allowing
thon's return as heir to the Empire but
Thon could Escape even if just s and
Ahsoka tried to go get Ezra so if Ahsoka
is this concerned about Thon and willing
to leave Ezra out there forever already
then why isn't the plan to just destroy
the mball and move on with their lives
Ezra free also thinking that name
dropping the best Star Wars novel will
make me forget how Disney uncanonized
the expanded universe and replaced it
with things like The Last Jedi and Rise
of Skywalker I did not forget and I did
not forgive Ahsoka doing that thing your
mom does when she waits for you to walk
away before telling you to do something
else
Master we received word better than
receiving Excel or access I
guess I thought it was
funny how can ahok and saine not hear
this the door to the ship is open
literally sounds like pots and pans are
having an orgy in
there that death Droid made it worse
first of all rude second of all you
crash landed an enemy territory after
being shot down and this is your first
thought you'll thank me they will not
I'm not just going to sit around and do
nothing with him I've heard that there
are four seasons of Star Wars Rebels
that at least on occasion tell a very
different version of that statement
but but you can't leave without
authorization Lieutenant wants the
audience to be shocked that one of the
characters on a show called Rebels is
now rebelling how come I have to do it
un told you don't I'm not sure but
what's more concerning is that Hara is
bringing her child on this very
dangerous Mission thanks for joining the
party Carson wouldn't miss it General
name dropping this random officer means
that I should already know who he is and
what other Star Wars related material
I've seen him in but I shouldn't have to
know who he is to understand a scene
quit pulling this crap Ahsoka I'm
actually at times not having a horrible
time with your show man it's tough to
get those words out have faith faith I
lost that a long time ago no I think
you're getting that confused with the
inability to have an erection without
the aid of a pill or a viewing of a
lightsaber battle they're easily
confused I keep hoping that this ball
will turn into a fantasm ball and Blades
will come out of it that will then Lodge
in people's foreheads and kill them I
have weird desires like the desire to
not have to remember who Carson is
witchcraft sure Balin because as history
has taught us immediately assuming
someone's involved in witchcraft always
well and no one gets set on fire or hung
from the rafters and then said things
that never happened wouldn't also
inspire a playright to create a 16th
century set play about witches that was
in fact a direct metaphor for the
McCarthy hearings in the Red Scare that
would never
happen cardio also I can't think of a
worse thing to do before a big battle
than Sprint for a full click click and a
half I don't know how clicks work let me
first shed my cloak so you'll know that
I'm very serious about this upcoming
lightsaber battle because otherwise you
might think I'm only partially invested
in these festivities you know my
favorite part of lightsaber battles it's
when they walk around in a circle and
stare into each other's eyes I mean who
needs actual lights saering in a
lightsaber battle when you have staring
and circular
stepping you see weeks of rampant
speculation about morac secretly being
Ezra or some other Padawan only to have
it revealed he's nothing more than
excess gas in a suit I'm just saying I
didn't expect that morac could have just
been defeated by a Pepto-Bismol chewable
you will regret this decision I mean
it's nowhere near the worst decisions
sub be makes in this episode so probably
not he never mentioned you well you see
Ahsoka that's because while you may have
a 15-year-old history they need to
invent a mysterious new antagonist for
your show that they could say has always
been in a galaxy far far away it's an
Nifty little trick The Writer's use
called Vader's dead and we need a new
villain before kylo shows up and you
find starting another War necessary I'm
not starting a war but thraw will and
you're going after thraw so he can start
the war so you're not exactly innocent
in the whole starting a war poor thing
Balin one Must Destroy in order to
create spoken like a toddler with a
crayon and a perfectly white wall iing
love this duel they don't just run in
swinging like crazy and screaming you
can feel the tension they're building
between Ahsoka and Balon as they size
each other up for a bit kind of feels
like an original trilogy duel and hot
damn is that a relief after that last
season am Mando once in all for a
promising fight to come the Jedi has
engaged Lord balum at the hen how long
until we receive the final coordinates
moments moment moments of convenience
also how does he not know exactly is the
download rapidly switching the time
remaining between 3 minutes and 3 days
throwing stones and Laser created map
houses why fight so hard to get a little
metal ball if you wanted to lay Morgan
just destroy the transmitter beaming
coordinates to her ship look at this
giant middle box that'd be way easier to
destroy than grabbing the map Source in
the middle of a fight you have no power
are you sure because she's doing the
hand thing usually the hand thing means
you have power I'm just saying maybe you
give the hand thing a little more time
to work before making such a declarative
statement your legacy like your Masters
was one of death and destruction was
there a scene of aoka slaughtering
children I missed because I'm pretty
sure she's killed the least number of
people in the Galaxy dumb line is
dumb I don't know why Jedi don't use the
force all the time I it wouldn't make
for great TV I get that but throwing
[__] into rocks would be my opening
move my finishing move and my middle
move and I might sprinkle in a ripping
of someone's spine out of their body
what does it make them tired tired only
grou looks tired when he uses it and
he's a baby is there a meter so we can
see the degrees of force each Jedi has
left would that make this more like a
video game yes is this already too much
like a video game also yes I get her
hand is hurting but Ahsoka dual wields
lightsabers all the time which means she
should be better equipped at fighting
one-handed more than just about anyone
it didn't need to come to this when you
know no other way well isn't this the
pot calling the other lightsaber
lightsaber I'd be more worried if Star
Wars didn't have a history of bringing
people back after they've fallen from a
great height Star Wars is becoming the
boy who cried dead Jedi and I don't like
it your family died on Mandalore because
your mastera didn't trust you wait no
Wikipedia tells me that Ahsoka had
nothing to do with sabine's parents
dying that was all moff Gideon in the
night of a thousand tears and we haven't
been given a flashback before now that
establishes otherwise why is this
exchange Lord B has remedied the
situation calculations are complete
already that was like half a second
after he established the connection how
did they not already have the the
calculations when the map field was
disrupted yes yes yes affirmative this
is full I thought Morgan was jamming
comms did that just stop once y Yang
fixed the radio why would Morgan allow
Communications to suddenly resume no one
will be following us except for the ex
Jedi who Indiana Jones the map into her
hand but other than her yeah no one's
going to be following you I I've got a
bad feeling well you should have taken
care of that before you left Hara warned
you there were no rest stops in this
system Jason oh wow I can't believe
they're using this place in the
liveaction series that I absolutely
recognize and is super duper meaningful
to me I loved it from that one cartoon
where they did the cartoon stuff hoay
for call backs that we all very much get
and aren't frustrated by at
all master maybe she thinks this is the
young Anakin who trained her and I'm
sure she still has great memories
attached to that Anakin however it still
feels like this franchise is trying to
rehabilitate a serial killer who killed
fing children I'll never be able to get
past that nor should I have
to
are those nuts come in home one this is
fulker rep Pete do you read us over and
did I catch a ner in there where you're
calling from a walkie-talkie is that a
note to fear in your voice I'm afraid
I've always been afraid
we better get moving together left
sarcasm a little more focused no
capes isn't a knife that's a knife I'll
try spinning that's a good trick oh no
you did not sh get green sh at me